Jason Kessler I work for cdk global come
the in Seattle that does a full-stack
software for auto retail and this is a
talk that is nothing to do with the auto
industry it's about an NLP package for
text visualization for Python it's
called scatter text and just to get it
out of the way this is the kind of thing
the package produces it's a comparison
of how Democrats and Republicans spoke
in the 2012 political convention so it's
it's four years ago or so it says so the
2016 political convention speeches all
right start 2012 four years ago it's a
little bit less heated than current
politics now and we'll sort of use this
as a running example but you'll get an
idea of what the colors mean what the
axes mean why there are these funny
strings in the chart what those two
columns are to the right and before we
get started if you have your laptop out
feel free to follow along with this talk
if you go to this bitly link I'll be
showing that throughout the presentation
to the first part of the talk will be
you know five or ten minutes and then if
you will also want to install this
package and another one that we'll be
using if you type pip 3 or just pip
install scatter text and age from name
they're optimized for Python 3 but they
should probably work in Python 2 so
scatter text a way to visualize how
different groups speak differently we
can see how they speak differently in
general like that that chart right there
and then in topic specific ways so how
do Democrats and Republicans talk
differently about the word jobs and
we'll get into word vectors and word
representations there and we'll look at
the intersection of different group type
so how do the gender and party of the
speaker intersect so we'll look at some
fun case studies about similar
sociolinguistic and sort of
computational social science studies and
the rest will consist of a bunch of code
examples and it should be a tutorial to
get you up and running and have you
scatter text so there's a lot of the
Python ecosystem that's involved in this
space a gentle a left-hand library
called empath which is pretty cool and
also the age from name library and we
make heavy use of
numpy so this should be a good toolkit
for computational social science and
really any kind of text exploration so
the first case study we'll talk about
was from OkCupid this is 2010 I think
and it's which words and phrases
statistically distinguish different
ethnic groups and genders and the source
was this massive amount of dating
profiles from OkCupid so for example
this one lady talks about hobos and
almond butter and other Bikram yoga
a third hundred years of solitude you
know maybe these different things they
talk about correlate to their genders or
their ethnic heritage so of course start
off by picking on myself so here are
words and phrases that distinguish white
men like in 2010 so you can see like tom
clancy van halen golfing yo ghostbusters
it already kind of sounds like like a
set of like very specific movie genres
The Big Lebowski its Ghostbusters was
still the the original sort of pre
remake and like you know hunting and
fishing you know sports apocalypse now
building things so you know 20 guitar
rock groan broke comedies things with
benches of dystopia so Christian rudder
who was the chief data scientist OkCupid
sort of had this you know small sort of
jokey passage to go along with the word
clouds said one of the really
interesting ones is words and phrases
that distinguish Latin men and when I
looked at this I wasn't familiar with a
lot of these categories and and of
course you know this segment contains
lots of other segments you know a ton of
different nationalities Cuban Dominican
Colombia etc but also like I had to
google what reggaeton was the sort of
speaks to the need for diversity among
data scientists frankly but also there
were things that were like really really
surprising that I hadn't thought about
before a big emphasis on the Armed
Forces on military on like boxing and
UFC but also you know I'm a funny dude
very funny outgoing and funny sayings
they're funny so it ends at the joke
basically if a latin dude tells you a
joke you should laugh
so another study that was a little bit
more recent was done on thousands of
really tens of thousands of facebook
statuses that were collected by
psychologists at UPenn and longer was
the head of the study and he presented
this at his Triple E eye tutorial in
2013 actually just in in Bellevue and he
put a lot of thought into how to make
word clouds to visualize how different
categories differed so here these are
words and phrases they're characteristic
of women in facebook statuses so these
are things like shopping excited the
heart and then you can see the color is
the relative frequency and the size the
words the correlation strength topics
that correlated with gender are sort of
put out into the spokes outside of it
and the good thing about word clouds is
they force you to hunt for the most
impactful terms so you end up looking at
the long tail in the process and you can
compactly represent a lot of words so
like ugh might have been if you rank
this list ugly might have been you know
ranked number 50 or something
but you'd still but now you still see it
by the harder mode the heart emoticon
which is highly correlated but we're
clouds go can go bad so they were
famously colored by Geoffrey's elleven
their tag clouds the mullets the
internet back in in 2005 that's like 12
years ago and longer phrases become a
lot more prominent just because they're
longer because the size of the text in a
word cloud the size of the phrase tends
to indicate its prominence also the
ranking is unclear like you don't know
whether which is he or the F word is
bigger and then also it's confusing in
terms of color and size does the color
indicate higher frequency or that it's
more correlated so word clouds have some
problems so actually Christian rudder
who had made the first set of word
clouds wrote this book called data Kazem
in 2014 which he proposed to fall
turn ative formulation and instead of
workouts for finding words and phrases
that were associated with particular
category you could just plot the word
frequencies out so on the y-axis you'd
see how words ranked with white men so
the word does very high but also on the
y-axis you'd see the x-axis you'd see
how words ranks with everyone else so
the word duh comes in the upper right
hand corner and also a bunch of stop
words but you have the word snow
mobiling falling directly on the y-axis
so only white men talked about
snowmobiling nobody else on the other
hand this is I think pre well I guess
this was post Gangnam style but no white
man talked about kpop in the sample of
Facebook statuses but it ranked above
above median with everyone else so you
can sort of see how close if like the
word fish is a very very low distance
the upper left-hand corner so you could
say that's highly correlated with white
men it's a very very simple metric and
kpop is a really big distance so you say
that wouldn't be that would be have a
low correlation and really what happens
is the smaller the smaller the distance
on the top left to higher the
association with white men it's a very
good very intuitive way of finding how
words correlated it might not be the
best metric but it's a very intuitive
one so we can actually see and this is
this is a picture that I drew of the all
the profiles that he collected the word
my blue eyes is this huge outlier in
terms of how they correlated with white
men and that was that was the most
correlated expression I don't know if
this actually refers to real data would
be very interesting to see how he did
this chart so let's go now to a demo so
if you're following along you can just
go to this bitly link pi data scatter
text1 so i'll just give everyone a
second to do that right now
okay the second is over does anyone
still need a little bit more time okay
great so this is the introduction to
scatter text so you can install the
scatter text through through a pip and
then if you just do import scatter test
as st that's the convention for
referring to scatter text I also make
heavy use of Spacey to do document
parsing and I just call this NLP equals
space easy and anglish if you don't want
to install Spacey your download the big
language model for English you can just
do NLP equals just a reg ax tokenizer
and sentence segment er which which
doesn't work very well but but it's a
lot faster and less efficient again does
anyone anyone need the bitly link again
or okay great so what you can do is uh
I've included the 2012 political
convention data set in scatter tack so
line three here is just pulling this and
we can see this gives you a panda's data
frame
the first entry oh yes oh whoa you still
have that Oh No
thank you
okay sorry about that
thank you very for saying something so
right you import scattered text as st
and then here just using NLT as a fourth
for the spacey
English parser so we can grab the 2012
convention data set and then we can see
we can look at the first line of it and
see that it lists the party of the
speaker the name of the speaker the
first and last name of the speaker and
the text of speech so here this is this
is Obama's keynote speech or is his
acceptance speech for the 2012
convention and we can see that in the
convention Democrats spoke a whole lot
more at least made more speeches 123
speeches to Republican 66 we can now
turn this into a scatter text corpus
object through this corpus from parsed
document factory where we specify which
category we're interested in the party
and we've parsed the corpus here and
then we've put up the Spacey document
the parsed document into this parse
column so let's take a look at this
metric called scale F score before we
look at the charts this is how we color
the terms the chart there are a lot of
ways to finding how terms are associated
we already looked at the corner score
now let's look at this this novel
technique called scaled F score the
intuition is that associated terms the
particular category have this high
category specific precision and recall
so if you just made a classifier does
this document contain this term or not
you could compute the precision recall
of that classifier and the F score is a
harmonic mean of the precision recall
and sort of there are no hyper
parameters here except how do you
ultimately scale the precision recall
and then how do you compute the F score
the beta parameter
so what we can do is we can see if we
just naively apply this we can get this
pandas dataframe where it's indexed on
terms that occur in the corpus how many
times we use by Democrats or Republicans
and then we can look at the relative
precision so Democrats are a little bit
more common where they spoke slightly
more words so even the word thaw has an
above 50% precision for Democrats but
and the recall is is 2% so this is it
was used essentially in two percent of
all spoken 2 percent of all times Oh
about two percent of all word spoken
where the word duh so it has a very high
scale of F score just because the recall
is is not super low so this doesn't
really work and you're ranked by a score
the solution here is we take the the
normal CDF of the precision and recall
scores and that will make them fold both
make them fall also between 0 and 1 but
it will kind of scale and standard
standard eyes the scores sort of so the
mean of the scores will be 0.5 so you'll
have you will you'll be able to
similarly scale both the precision
recall and what we see is once we apply
this and then we again take the harmonic
mean of the descale the normalized
precision and recall we can see the word
middle-class comes up is the most
correlated term for Democrats that it
was used 108 148 times by Democrats and
18 times our Republican the word auto
occurs 37 times by Democrats but 0 times
our Republican so it's doing something a
little bit different than the for
example the log odds ratio which is
another very popular technique if we
look at this four corner score corner
score is much more strict in terms of
the precision of these terms and it just
favors terms that have Precision's of a
hundred percent
so we can see again the top ten
Democratic terms the top ten Republican
terms Republicans talk about
unemployment we can do better
Liberty government they also talked
about odd things like the Olympics since
Romney had run the Salt Lake City
Olympics so let's go ahead and see how
we can get to these charts so sort of
the naive way of creating one of these
charts is you can go ahead and just rank
the terms based on their raw frequencies
and this chart is almost entirely
dominated by by stop words now there are
some researchers like James Pennebaker
and UT Austin who think soft words are
reveal some some very important mental
states like you use I much more if
you're lying and if you're not lying or
talking to a superior women use more
personal pronouns things like that but
but for the most part this doesn't allow
us to do a particularly good content
analysis of the of the corpus now if
instead we scale by the log frequency we
get something it looks a little bit
better and actually the quarter scores
of these of both categories work pretty
well so middle-class Auto fair doing a
log scale just to sort of normalize for
the zipfian distribution it's sort of
normalize for that but we still get a
whole lot of white space in the chart we
can only label part of the point and
stop words still take up a big chunk of
it so instead of ranking terms by a raw
frequencies we can rank terms based on
their percentile just based on their
their ranks and the wonderful thing
about this is that the stop words are
essentially minimized into the far upper
right hand corner just like they were on
the rudder diagram and then this spreads
out throughout the entire chart the
issue here is that for example on this
point right here
there could be actually and if you click
on these points though they'll show
context but right over here
could be hundreds of words that are
stacked on top of that point and all of
them none of them are accessible because
we can only mouse over the first one in
the center phase by the way these charts
are done in d3 there is a custom point
labeling algorithm that's created using
a package called cosy that was developed
at u-dub to automatically that easily
makes it easy to write an algorithm to
find places to put labels that don't
overlap anything else
so one solution to this this problem the
stacking problem is you can just jitter
the points so that way we can randomly
add some small quantity to each of the
points and then spread them out the
issue with doing that is the distance to
the upper left-hand or lower right-hand
corner is really important and
especially when you get up here into
sort of the higher frequency terms you
just get confetti you get words that are
out of order that are very difficult to
read and plus it just kind of messes
around these are always listed by the
scale of F scores you can get like the
word cars comes up here and this is
ranked a little bit too highly for
Democrats so you can mess up your your
corner score especially visually that's
very important so the the preferred
solution took me a little while to come
up with this but you just break ties you
don't jitter but you break ties
alphabetically what this does is you'll
see these like little sequences of terms
that all have the same frequency and
that are all just late atop each other
because you're breaking ties
alphabetically so here you have a bond
and bond came in two or so these are in
alphabetical order sort of for these
exact frequencies
so we can also do a couple more types of
visualization with scatter tack so we
can use this this package to visualize
the differences between different term
finding algorithms so for example using
L to penalize logistic regression is
tends to be a preferred way of looking
at term importance so here we can just
rank the terms instead of by the corner
score by their regression coefficients
and what we can see is using a pretty
some fairly aggressive parameters with L
to penalize logistic regression a high C
parameter we can see that a lot of stock
words do get ranked very highly here so
like for apostrophe s and of our good
indicators of a speaker being Republican
which which doesn't make a lot of sense
intuitively so right now the
recommendation here is not to use help
to penalize logistic regression for
finding terms that are associated there
also other issues that you can
potentially get some balancing out
effects so we can see how this compare
it to scale test score which looks
pretty different
so here the y-axis of scale of F score
again the the x-axis here at the log
frequency ranks so scaled F score tends
to like terms that are not incredibly
unfrequent but that aren't super
frequent so the software's are ranked
somewhat highly like the word Jill over
here is actually ranked lower than the
in terms of association with Democrats
but we can sort of get the middle of the
the middle of the the frequencies or
ranked pretty highly so we can get
interesting semantic information based
in this range of frequencies and then we
can also compare this to things like log
odds ratio with a which has been very
popular with a uninformative prior where
here this really favors terms that never
occur and I
category and shrinks everything else and
then also we can look at coroner score
which says something similar but is even
more aggressive in how it regularizes
terms okay great so let's take a break
from pure word frequencies and let's
look at something else so let's look a
gender discriminating terms and we'll
take a step back so we'll just set this
up just the same way we did earlier
let's look at this package called age
from name what this does is this will
tell you what someone's age is but also
based on social security data of how
many people had a particular first name
in a given year and life expectancy data
it will impute the probability that
someone's if someone's name is Kelsey
what's the probability they're male so
right now some of the same was Kelsey
they'd have a three percent chance of
being male but if you adjust their
minimum age and say okay they're at
least seventy years old than theirs then
there's an 83% chance they're male now
at any given year you can see in 1930
there was like a hundred percent chance
that Kelsey would be a man but now in
twenty at least in 2015 the last date
that I checked there's a three percent
chance that Kelsey will be a man so you
can see how names change over time so
it's important if you want to impute
someone's gender from their name it
helps to know their age also helps to
know the date of the document so now
let's go ahead and let's take the
convention data set and we'll assign
speakers a gender we'll just assume that
they're making a lot assumption or at
least thirty five years old and we'll
say they're male if there's at least a
90% probability they're male and they're
female if there is less than a 10%
probability they're they're male so we
can't tell with Barak it probably wasn't
a very frequent name when he was born
but Michelle is definitely female and
Richard is definitely now and we can get
all but 19 speakers so this is pretty
good and now we can see the language use
in these conventions
that differ between genders and this is
kind of cool so we can see here that
women the female speakers talked a lot
about health care and particularly
health coverage they talked about their
daughters planned as in Planned
Parenthood
so level the playing field and then
these also sort of tend to correspond
with Democratic talking points but these
were will sort of see how these these
intersect with gender but the word
ladies to these very gender terms ladies
mom also birth control First Lady
daughters for men it was there was a lot
of rhetoric and policy so the word yet
you know trillion dollars a debt being
consulting talking about Israel is
mostly Democrats talking about Israel
the private sector confidence the poor
energy policy private equity so it sort
of it tells you something about how the
parties position their speeches where
the female speakers are speaking
directly toward toward female voters
potentially and now we can even see how
gender and party intersects so we can
graph down here how the scale def score
is differ on the y-axis we can see the
scale def score of how democratic award
is and the y-axis how female award is so
in the lower left hand corner you can
see Republican words that were
characteristically spoken by men's these
were unemployment government Church
trillion debt Bain is in Bain Capital
like the dollar sign and then in the
upper right hand corner we can see
Democratic words that were spoken by
women predominantly so we have the word
women and woman and this is also sort of
an interesting reason why I don't stop
list because if you see the same word
appearing both times with the same
morphology than that's that's of added
evidence that it's salad
and then also the word M which is kind
of an interesting stop word that got in
here and then again you can see more
actually I think M may have been neutral
but it's a women was was highly
associated with Democrat woman less so
also insurance in the word vote was very
interesting that this was a very
characteristic of democratic limit and
then Republican women you have success
and they really like Ronald Reagan and
then also talking about Ann Romney and
then one tie in that we had there's a
recently released package it was a high
paper in 2016 that creates essentially
crowdsource topic models that correspond
to an emotion or a particular topic that
occurred in language around 2016 it's a
very interesting paper and I suggest
that you download this this package is
just called empath and you can find it
in the slides or in the the tutorial but
you can see one of the interesting
things was two women talked about things
that were feminine they talked about
dance also obviously you have this big
like medical emergency and health issue
also children and family while men
talked about jobs blue-collar jobs and
white-collar jobs technology and
journalism and programming and also the
poor which is very interesting so let's
let's look at how this intersects with
word vectors and with with deep learning
which has been very popular at this
conference if you want to call word
Tyvek deep learning if there's just a
hidden layer so again we load the
convention set just as we normally do
and
for the first example we can use Jen sim
to train a word to that model and if
you've ever trained a word to avec model
in Jensen before you know there's quite
a bit of hyper parameter tuning and
there's a little bit of a dark art to
training these things if you don't have
a gargantuan amount of data so I won't
go into that but there's a lot of
literature on how to best train word
representations but we can see
intuitively that this model performs
pretty well so taxes affordable cuts
prescription fair tax opportunities not
great we can see how this relates to say
Obama oh no and I actually let's not but
so for example we can look at a
particular target term so I have the
term jobs here and we can color words
that are associated with one category or
another these are using penalize
log-odds ratio just to see words that
have a p-value of less than 0.05 that
are associated with Democrats or
Republicans those are oh yes thank you
those are those are colored and
democratically Republicans are colored
red and then we look at the word
similarity scores between the word jobs
and all the colored terms and then we
can see how the two parties talked about
jobs so Republic with Democrats this
model was middle-class auto industry a
plan fair so it wasn't great job cuts
the Republicans success and talking
about job-killing regulations another
way of doing this instead of training
bespoke topic models is it's built into
scatter text or you can just use spaces
come and crawl spaces comma crawl word
vectors which which tend to work much
better for this application so you can
see like the word workers occur is
highly associated with Democrats as as
companies so here you can see it's
really kind of labor versus business or
how Democrats and Republicans talk about
jobs differently so job creators versus
workers
is a pretty interesting result is
intuitively plausible and that is it for
the presentation so thank you very much
and are there any questions thanks a lot
he's curious I have two questions the
first one is I noticed some multi-or
expressions and in these plots curious
how you how you treated those as single
tokens okay so I use just the PMI trick
okay to find multi-award expressions I
just looked at my grams so people then
just like 40 and so you include a sample
corpus with scatter texts and that
includes like the pre-processed yeah
that just includes like a basically CSV
or data frame just of the data that I
show well so my other question was about
a scaled escort I was wondering if you
could just talk about that a little bit
more it's like the motivation and they
maybe point to some literature yeah so
there's no literature this is the letter
chair for scalp escort okay so the
motivation is that a lot of these other
two multivariate scores like logistic
regression tend to have these weird
balancing out things where you'll have
words that aren't really correlated or
there's some relation there's a
multicollinearity and you'll get funny
weights so it's looking at unigram
scores and looking at what's very
popular is it log odds it's informed a
prior that requires you to pick a
specific background corpus to balance
out against so scale that score tends to
be hyper parameter free and it just
doesn't a log odds ratio which is the
problem with a lot of these just looking
at your examples in particular teams
like a lot of things would be further
differentiated if you could look at
engrams for example Jobs was
differentiated well probably good jobs
it has a very different party
affiliation than job creators or free
market versus Free Press or something
like that
yeah so a lot of these but I do see in
some cases you have some short phrases
that are several words how do you decide
where to pull off the short phrases
versus the individual words silly
just use actually the ACL reviewer said
the exact same thing so if you're going
to ACL in Vancouver this will be a demo
where you can can muck around with this
but but the idea is it's just the same
answer that we it was just by grams for
in order to speed up the computation and
I just looked at a PMI filter to see
which by grams look like they were
statistically probable but yes I think
it would benefit from more engrams if
there was more computation time and also
it's harder to label longer expressions
on the chart so moosa' your reasoning a
prism would or shorter freeze and any
attempt attributed a model for
understanding a sentence for studying a
sentence to understand a sentence so I
think you could conceivably use this to
to plot say if you had a probability
that a sentence was generated by a
particular corpus or projective you
train language models on both categories
you could see the probability that this
sentence was generated by this category
and then plot those sentences in a
similar fashion but I hadn't thought
about that at an interesting question
hi so well how would you recommend using
scatter text if you're plotting
something with more than two categories
so that's a good question so if you see
the intersection between gender and
political party there you can do like
that's like like two sets of categories
otherwise you can just do a bunch of one
versus all plus it's not very elegant I
have been thinking about ways of
approaching multiple categories which
are a little bit different but I can
talk to you about those offline to know
for questions so you mention about P PMI
theater like we part of the code is
about this oh so there is so I just
included this internally the idea that
PMI filter is you just try to figure out
how probable two words are consecutively
and then see what the probability is of
that and gram and you look at the ratio
that really the log ratio of those
probabilities but if you see in let's
see I should have this so I had this PMI
filter threshold this is just looking at
two times that log probability so if you
just Google PMI multi-word expression
you'll see a ton of literature about
this any more questions okay thank you
so much thank you
[Applause]